[Music]
we got units in the house this butcher
Danny wake you what's that Jackie stood
Nick with 400 years old this key right
here yeah holding onto it tight for the
door weird here at the main mush inside
you know be amazing to see since you
have a lot of tourists here it would be
amazing to see these tourists come
through if there was a little
information center where they can
approach it you have some pamphlets
maybe a translation of the time this
would be amazing we could be fulfilling
our duty of Dawa sharing this message I
love to see that I think that would fit
in amazing here in the main mush to add
our Information Center let's do it
Bosnia pamphlets like what's Islam Islam
on Jesus all these other things general
topics I think we could do a Bosnian
what do you think make it happen in
Charla
yeah it's a country that's not really
visited much by people like in Australia
and New Zealand please
that's all father city and what were you
saying about this place right here the
Seven Brothers this is like a tomb
we call it Torbay of Salaam brachii it's
like a story seven good people were
buried here huh and what people like to
do with people without knowledge you see
you have on each door I have like a
small zip or you put money through every
time you put some money inside you like
make draw but people believe that's
actually the people who are buried here
it will help them to connect to a lot
people don't know what they're doing so
they're doing a big mistake seems like a
lot of people who I've interviewed over
the years who've left Christianity
Catholicism because of this very thing
they wanted to pray directly to the
creator and they're pure monotheism and
they left what was called we know is
[ __ ] but it's strange that we're finding
it are you doing can you explain to us
like what you were doing
there's a Russian I believe Coleco
salute which and gorgeous and ours and
I'm also back and now as you said on
most of our queries I despise
so what he says he actually doesn't
really know much about the place he says
what he knows is that seven people who
had the same faith who died the same way
I buried here I noticed that you were
you were praying who are you praying to
Molly so over the country Pakistani much
does Malcolm is semantic our Protima
miss Somali mala the priests Vega II
amino an action focus on protecting us a
request ago Justice Scalia say on a wall
is an ass okay so what he says basically
he prays only to Allah but what he does
here is he tries to get people who are
buried here to pray for them to Allah
have you have you ever had time to
really study the core fundamental belief
of Islam called tawheed the studious
know Islam started he was LOM told funny
some posh immortal eco-feminist approach
into the cheeto some dose Authority says
you know the beautiful thing about our
Deen is that Allah has told us through
the prophets awesome that we don't need
to go through anybody that Allah hears
sees all and we can go straight to him
we don't have to go through any
middleman is that beautiful yes to a
large ocean home guichen Amida that's a
directory i'm over achamma basic equipo
Cernik cuz I thought I probably passed
far was sloshed crosses all started he'd
do you say traveler tow he said some
people spell it wrong they say definite
though he'd yeah this was one of the
things that really attracted me to Islam
is that direct connection with Allah did
I didn't have to pray to a human being
to a sank to an angel to anyone other
than the laws alone it was so beautiful
no more
they might directly connect to Sabo
Gonzales Dannemora each brinicle
paparazzo stars now that the Astoria to
connect really really met him that that
got purveyors also spurred on and I've
interviewed hundreds of hundreds of
Christians and and other people of other
religions and what they love about Islam
these strange superstitions incantations
these things that they found in
Christianity and Catholicism and now
some some people see it coming into
Islam you know which is not a part of it
they love this teaching of it that you
don't need to have do any strange
superstitions there's no one between you
Allen law and this is something that
really attracts people it goes before
our human nature question ludicrous to
scientist on Islam
Oprah smoked oh gosh the name of punah
suniye islam and agree much to correct a
direct way so they put a name somali to
bogota that's the beautiful thing that
our dean you know see every messenger
that allah sent they exactly came to
call people away from this kind of thing
the human beings sometimes would deviate
and they would start to put
intermediaries between them and Allah so
Allah will send these messengers Moses
Abraham Jesus David Ishmael Isaac and
the last and final messenger problem
Hamid peace and blessings be upon him
and they all taught us in the last fall
motion Pro Muhammad sallallaahu
so that we don't need no middlemen we
don't pray to anybody
no dead Saint in the ground we don't
even know who at the end of the day is
officially a saint who's close to a law
unless it's mentioned in the crown in
the Sunna so we pray only to Allah we
don't have to pray to anybody else
because there's a very thin line there
and a very thin line is what we're
trying to stay away from because it's
the one thing that will prevent someone
from entering into the mercy of Allah
into the agenda and could get someone
into the Hellfire by committee shik by
setting up partnership for law so may
Allah protect us from that and may we
only do something it's just so simple to
understand and do that we only make duaa
that we only pray that my life my
sacrifice is the losses in the Quran is
only to the one God Allah pure
monotheism they should put a sign it
this yeah so we know what we're talking
about before when you this is like the
101 of tawheed you see we have the three
categories of Touhey so when you study
those three to lordship allows names and
attributes of worship so these things
when they're connected they're all one
so my worship my dua my prayer in this
case only for Allah nobody else Allah is
all-hearing all-seeing all-knowing so he
has those perfect names and attributes
the only belong to him he's won in that
so anyone else who comes along and says
some Imam or anyone can hear I'll see
y'all that's a breaking of the toe he
and when you really know toe heed then
you know your Deen and that's when we
were asking the brother had he studied
this he said not really so advice for
all the people out there in humanity
Muslims non-muslims and this is what you
see tonight yet Allah says when they
study Islam and they get to know the toe
heat they accept it's not so then you
have Muslims who really don't know that
the he'd told he the pure monotheism
then they jump in and they
caught up into these things and there's
the hadith for the Prophet SAW some said
that one knowledgeable person is heavier
on Shaitaan than a thousand worshippers
because what happens if you don't have
the knowledge you'll get taken for a
ride interesting thing that we as
Muslims should understand that we are
much a bigger price for Shaitaan so that
Shaitaan will do much harder work on us
then when somebody who's not a Muslim so
I say like when when you're not a Muslim
Shaytan did his job but if you're Muslim
he will do anything to trick you to fool
you so this thing is one of these
examples where Muslims bring
hard-working and he unfortunately
succeeding to trick many Muslims who
don't have basic knowledge he basically
thought that that they don't pray to
these people that this goes to charity
but we know from the example that people
don't understand it in that way did they
understand it completely wrong so they
should at least poor assigned to explain
or why would you even put money where
the grave is like we know that this
tradition is wrong like whoever reads it
it's obvious it's wrong but now for one
interest or another is being wrapped
around to fit everybody but well we see
a lot of times people want to easily
take a shortcut so now you'll see many
people not really studying the Deen not
praying not doing many of the other acts
so you want to take a shortcut and you
want to put you know a dollar a mark a
penny what other case and now you don't
think you can get a shortcut there's no
shortcuts in the deed so you have to
live the Deen according to the Quran the
verbatim word of God Allah and the
sinner so we don't find any of this in
their sanctioning this but we do find
doing things like this are what
constitutes [ __ ] works he said though
there's been here for five hundred years
like this the common argument we get
when we get to these things that are not
not comparable with Sharia
it's been here for five hundred years
600 years why would somebody come with
something new to change it so we can see
how the Chaitra tricks people to give
some excuses and not look at it straight
and how is one one thing I advised my
brothers and sisters out there is
anything that a lost want Allah has made
prohibited it's clear you don't have to
do a lot of research so spend some time
make dua directly to Allah and do your
homework and insha'Allah Allah will make
it clear but if we're going to follow
our Neffs our desires and blindly
imitate our people we've seen doing
things we're gonna fall into these trips
and traps of Shaytan we're gonna block
ourselves for the mercy of the law and
get which is vast we're gonna fall into
the we're gonna get pimped by the
Shaitaan and we're shaped I'm gonna end
up and Hellfire and we don't want to end
up in Hellfire so learn to Touhey the
pure monotheism and stick to the Khurana
Sunnah and we'll be successful shell on
this life in the next this is more of a
superstition some precision if people
are here looking for some kind of good
look good for it's good luck do
something good to happen to them so
they're coming here why they gonna come
from all over places yeah and you see
this this is an epidemic you see this
with Christians with Hindus that's all
and this is what white you see Islam is
unique because Islam cancels all this
Islam on the Touhey the pure monotheism
such a limit
line you can't cross that line of
associating partners with other than law
so you don't pray to anyone to stick to
a stone to a bone to a human being a
dead person in the ground
it's nothing in creation but the one who
created you that's so simple and easy to
understand but people always want to
take a shortcut a shortcut and you this
is a shortcut so this this comes into
the effect of good luck charms like a
rabbit's foot you know cat it crossing
the street black cat coming down bill
John oh look you know the black magic
and all this stuff now you want to throw
this in there and try make it hello this
is it's not halal and Saddam it's [ __ ]
and we need to call it for what it is
and insha'Allah people who don't know
maybe then get the message maybe they
know and if you didn't know now you know
luck and throwing this is new Shaitaan
stuff comes to rid us of all these
superstitions these strange incantations
all these strange there's so many
strange things going on people
worshipping animals pieces people
worshipping dead people in greys people
doing all sorts of superstitions
believing in silly things crazy things
way out there things that's the beauty
of Islam Islam is logical Islam doesn't
call you to go against reason and this
is why people go away
from what we call the religion or the
Deen is a way of life people go away
from religion altogether because of
these strange things but believe you
mean that everything in Islam that the
Creator told us to do it doesn't go
against reason and logic so if you see
something that defies a lot of times
reason and logic and again we don't put
our logic over revelation saying that
but in prayer in fasting in the worship
of Allah all these things giving zakat
all these things stayin away from
fornication from promiscuity and the
hijab marriage avoiding sexual
immorality all these things - huh dude
all these things and go on and on when
you look into the wisdoms behind it you
see
for the benefit of humanity when you see
a lot of these superstitions have
nothing to do that Salaam they're weird
doesn't make sense it's not part of the
Deen this one let's go walk it through
said ievo we just stopped at that place
and I'm sure a lot of people can take
some of the advice one thing that's very
important is that along with having the
attention intention the proper intention
that you do things solely for the sake
of your Creator for Allah you got to
have knowledge it has to be knowledge
based and that action so there's no
three components that action has to be
based not according to my desires I
can't worship Allah according to my
desires it has to be according to the
Quran that was sent piecemeal over 23
years as a mercy to mankind and
according to how the best example
illustrating how to worship Allah we
find that in the Sunda the authentic
sunnah of the last the final messenger
prophet muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him she had the crown in the Sunnah
and then of course the understanding of
the best of generations who understood
the Deen the best
those are his companions so that's the
formula for success then you have these
great Allah MA these scholars were out
there of the both halves and beyond you
stick to that in sha Allah and you'll be
okay
why are the corner
[Music]
it poochy
anybody ever explain to you what's being
said how are you
has anybody ever explain to you what
goes on in the moss what the ID on your
hearing means some of it yeah I know
some yeah share with me what you know oh
well I know about the Imam there sits
particularly then you know what he's
with it what there Don just the time it
started with Allahu Akbar Allahu Akbar
which means God is the greatest God is
the greatest vinick's says a shadow and
i love love declaration of that there's
nothing worthy of worship except the
creator in arabic allah yes then i bear
what's the Shahada this is how much
someone is because in this event
this is islam this is the whole
teachings right there there's some duck
so then the testimony goes as follows
that there's nothing worthy of worship
except the creator and I bear witness
that Muhammad is the messenger yes now
if you didn't know this that when you
testify that Muhammad is the messenger
the last message is sent by God you
automatically include Jesus Moses
Abraham and all the preceding messages
because guess what they came they came
with Islam and this is what we practice
in Islam you know what Islam means yes
what don't go you told me Islam is to
submit your will out to the cradle of
and this is how you achieve peace right
so you have the five pillars then you
have now the first pillar we just
discussed the pure monotheism of
declaring first of negation you're
saying look I'm not going to worship
Jesus it's not gonna worship the money
in my pocket I'm not sure workers just
stick a stone about nothing other than
the one who created me makes sense yes I
just goes with our nature and then now
if I testify that like if you guys did
that right now you'd be considered
Muslim that's all simple and easy it is
then you'd say okay now you got to
fulfill because talk is cheap you got to
fulfill those action this with the
pillars praying five times a day giving
in the charity zakat yes fasting during
the month of Ramadan
and then you're there versus you to you
know the African Americans Muhammad Ali
the Malcolm X you have the transatlantic
that came over this injustice inhabited
african-american the majority of those
that were brought unjustly to the
Americas for Muslims yes you guys ready
to come back to your roots very
interesting do you agree with the things
I'm sure I agree with what you've said
yes now let me add one more thing if you
guys come from a Christian background
there are take over for super did you
did you know that Islam is the only
non-christian faith which makes it an
article of faith because there's a sixth
article of faith and faith in there
that you believe in the messages to
believe is Jesus is one of the mightiest
messengers ever sent if you deny Jesus
you don't buy yourself a one-way ticket
to the Hellfire doctor so you have to
honor him not as a God or as a literal
son of God but as a Messenger of God
that he came with the same message as
Abraham Moses Jesus Mohammed worship
only one God here o Israel as the Bible
said the Lord thy God is one that's
that's the universal way of life from
the beginning the first man Adam all the
messengers until the last message about
Muhammad and then he came with the
evidence the Quran so anybody who's
sincere with genuine looks at the Quran
because I can make these claims everyone
can make claims but now you put it to
the test and you read it open it up you
say hold on there's no way this will
come from human danger so I know about
him going out into the desert and and
then
stood a bell who's giving him the word
same angellist is that God Almighty
communicated to the other prophet just
same thing from here yeah he would
seclude himself the people used to
worship idols right yes so then from
there the message came to him and then
he came out to the people and deliver
that message for so what we have now
because one we have a believable message
like when I talked about I'm not time
while worshiping statues or aliens or
flying monsters we're talking my
worshipping the one who created us then
from there now we look at the Quran we
look at the miracle of the Quran how
it's been preserved over 23 years we
have it now you can have a translation
in Bosnian and Spanish and English but
the original is in the Arabic so now
when you look at the preservation of the
crown when you look at the things the
prophecies that are mentioning there
when you look at the facts not fiction
in there of the human development of the
embryo and other facts that there's no
way that this human being this bedouin
of the desert could have known these
things and then other predictions that
from his life that he had prophesized
and you're like hold on leaving the
message this book could not have come
from him or group Amman now you're left
with no other alternative but to either
turn away or to submit to Allah God told
us to do yeah so I could he tell me
about that the type of Islam it was
practicing in this area
God Almighty when he sent to prayer then
you have the Prophet Muhammad same thing
as during the time of Jesus if you're
living during the time of Jesus you'd
have to not go ahead and jump over his
teachings you had to go now worship Him
but believed in the message he came in
he came with the NGO and he was a
walking instruction manual to that same
thing during the time of Moses the Torah
he came with the Torah and then he was
explaining that now you have problem
Ahamed who came with the Quran and his
Sunna his example so those who follow
his Sunna there was lay with him soon
these the followers of the Sunna
so this is what you have here yeah yeah
so have you got Ike see you know some
fried others yes it's very nice to see
you guys here also yeah but we've
traveled we've traveled a lot in Turkey
we traveled a lot in Turkey and we've
also been around an Albanian you guys
are like family already you see like you
know I'm very passionate about sharing
the message there's a lot of
misconceptions about Islam yes yes and
and and what we try to do is you know
through my program clear the
misconceptions deliver the message share
it there's no coal version you can't
force them on but but we've seen so many
people studying Islam but they have
never been invited so we also let people
know that at anytime anyone this is not
a way of life that's exclusive to their
border Bosnia
this is for you for you for everyone yes
yes so at anytime if someone feels like
look I just want to connect with my
Creator
I believe Muhammad is the messenger as
shadow and let you know hey the Lord was
shadow under mohammed rasoolallah
that's the Shahada there's nothing
worthy of worship like that Don we
started with that I declared it there's
nothing worthy of worship except the one
who created me the crater that happens
in earth and air and Arabic Allah
Aramaic language Jesus spoke people say
Aloha hello Elohim right yes and now I'm
gonna live according to God's will not
my desires you're a Muslim and you take
those baby stuff and you start learning
and learning growing implementing as
much as you can and even you make a
mistake you turn to God the most
merciful the most loving and you keep
moving forward ahead of me like you get
off you fall off the bike but you get
right back on yeah I think the prayers
gonna start I know I would have gone in
but I don't go in wall prayer if your
questions I'll answer I'm gonna go pray
what's your name Thank You Jerry
yeah nice meeting you this would be like
nice meeting you
did you go put money in there no no no
it's wrong why not there's people doing
it there's many people doing it there
are lots of people doing even
non-muslims yeah yeah I know even
non-muslims doing because it's a it's
additional Bosnia and people think it's
gonna help them you know achieve so what
do you tell somebody who was about to
put a quarter in there and they asked
you like should I do it you said no one
they said why why not I mean put the
quarter in there if you want to you know
that money goes to charity I guess I
don't know if you want to put it to
charity give it to charity it's okay but
if we think that you're putting a
quarter in there and praying to these
seven graves of seven people that used
to be good people back here knowing like
hundreds of years ago and they're not
gonna help you there are dead people and
people cannot help you and in terms of
you know what's what especially those
people they can't help you it doesn't
make sense
I don't I tried to say nothing because
it's very complicated to explain to
people that's not that's faith that's
not gay but and usually they say that
they don't pray because of that people
from that people it's like cheating I
will give you some money but please take
the let's say God that's he sent me some
good stuff so it's like cheating but the
people it's really don't understand that
if you try to explain them and if you
really explain them they understand they
really understand because that that
people they cannot help themselves how
they can spell to help their others it's
called like the Seven Brothers
and you see people putting quarters and
marks and dimes in here I was thinking
if someone came to you and asked you a
sheikh is your Hafiz you know someone
who knows the Deen very well been
studying it what would you be a response
to someone who's about to put a quarter
or what
your response to someone like that who
came to ask your advice I think that
people the new are in some kind of
trouble when you have difficulties in
life people are hanging for a straw
basically they are looking everywhere
just to find the solution but the
Buddhists they many times they don't
they don't want to hear but isn't you
have to change you have to change your
circumstances you have to work on
yourself you have to change you'll have
to work on your Deen on your life and
everything you'd have to change your
habits that's not easy to do the easy
part is to throw a coin and you have or
for example on the in the vest they have
like we have wishing well wishing wells
yes it's all a coin and they make a wish
but that's just a wish you know if you
want to make something happen in life
you have to make a plan and go for it
and do it nothing will come out of the
blue that's their response they have to
work on the with the people to give them
the message that they have to work on
themselves they had to change themselves
they have to learn they their Dean they
have to learn the Dean they have to for
example when you buy LCD or when you buy
some machine you read the instruction
manual but when it comes some other
important things in life like getting
children who reads the books about
children who attends lectures do I'll be
like I know when it comes to to our Dean
which is the most precious thing we have
you have to learn it you have to read it
you have to attend lectures you have to
listen to the chase you have to do what
they say you want you can't do it
anything on yourself and I believe when
we come to the best part people don't
listen
listen to they can be very stubborn
so had people have to change themselves
in order for everything to be better
beautiful advice no wishing wells in
Islam yes basically I can wish for
something to happen the just just a wish
it's an illusion I have to go for it I
have to do something for example our
prophet sallallaahu excelent he had to
work for everything you had to do
everything no shortcuts no shortcuts
basically that's life in shortcuts you
should work we strive for something
better we achieve something good in this
life and in the next you have to use
this life as a means to get to the other
but if you don't forgive you don't plant
seeds what can you what can you yes what
can you reap
well the on the other side friend just
told me a story colleague he was
travelling with him my car and they were
passing by next well-tuned this man
because he was driving he stopped
promptly he stopped quickly and said he
almost forgot to put some money in the
tube and like make a wish he thought
it's bad luck if he doesn't stop yeah
the superstition about things like that
is huge in our country
and yeah the guy the same guy doesn't go
to the prayer doesn't go to message he
doesn't have the same fear of Allah if
he misses a prayer but he has a fear if
he doesn't but this if he doesn't stop
there
it's like superstition it's like bad
luck if you don't stop at this
towba to give some money to put some
money there and make a wish place the
camera and talk about the historical
London first of all they might have
fears about was due to its history
considering coming over but they don't
question mister your feet to you to them
Islam being misrepresented in the media
to be able to hear that to feel like
you're at home
go to some places some other countries
your wife's wearing a job this is just
wearing a job if you have looked like a
Muslim you don't have that same
welcoming feeling but here like you've
come home serious place
Schmidlapp humming that I Salam alaykoum
greetings a piece of midi air host of
the d show air and islam channel and
what's amazing about Sutter fo is that
it's right next door to you so why would
you visit in the heart of Europe you
have Bosnia this is like the Jerusalem
of Europe and there's so much profound
history here when I talk to Christians
Christians are amazed because they were
the true followers of Jesus peace be
upon him who we love dearly so when you
look into the history of the Bosnian
people there were those who separated
from the church they believed in Jesus
but they didn't pray to Jesus our
worship Jesus and then when Islam came
the call to worship the Creator alone
not to associate partners with him but
to worship the one and only one God
Allah they ended up accepting it and
this is the history of the people so now
when you go ahead and you look even
deeper you see like in here in this area
we have the greatest genocide after
World War two that happened in this
country and you saw the preservation of
churches you saw how even Muslims were
saving at one time Jews by putting them
in the Islamic garb the the niqab so
when you learn all of these these
histories it debunks much of the false
accusations that are out there by the
ate machine by the Islamic Oaks so this
is one of the things amongst many we're
not going to talk about the food and the
people in the soul of the country that
you'll get to experience here in Bosnia
because they have fresh food they bring
the fresh food in the morning and when
they're done it's not like when you go
back to many of these places they
microwave the food it's if you don't
know it's been sitting for days
experience the people now and I
recommend going a little bit sometimes
you have where there's a line here it
says we're East meets West so you feel
like you're in a different time a
different time zone literally like an
ottoman empire and then you had the
austro-hungarian time the buildings are
different you get away from the city and
you see the mountains and we got to
experience some of the the rafting here
between two of the canyons
and the rivers are flowing then you see
the waterfalls and you get out and you
just you know the the welcoming feeling
from the people and not that that you
fear that sometimes many Muslims sad to
say are experiencing just recently you
had two Muslims
flushing the toilet twice and waving to
each other they'd even say Aloha I've
bet or Salam alaikum now it's just like
body language and they got kicked off
the plane you don't have that experience
here it's totally different come
experience it and inshallah we can hook
up because already we made the
connection from London to survival and
inshallah maybe you'll find me here